[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Lisa is
in Frederickburg Virginia hi Lisa how
are
you hi Dave it's a pleasure to speak
with you you too how can we
help um so I have a pretty complex um
question and I I've heard your last um
segment previously about shacking up and
sharing finances and things like that
you're not married so please don't chew
me out as a as a disclaimer um I
co-signed um for my boyfriend for a car
um he owes about 32,000 or I should say
we owe about 32,000 and he's been behind
on the payment um I've been denied for
two personal loans um for the difference
of the vehicle um due to my debt to
income ratio so I'm really trying to
figure out how to get from under this
car um
completely and uh is this your
ex-boyfriend no parent oh
okay well it sounds like he can't afford
the
car yeah it sounds like he couldn't
afford it when you guys got the loan
considering he needed a cosigner and he
hadn't paid the
payments yeah what's the car worse so
why is he not selling the
car he can't afford it and he's doing
damage to his girlfriend there's two
reasons to get rid of the
car yeah so the the private sale um
based on Kelly Blue Book was 19,000
tradeing value is 177,000 um like said
we owe 32,000 so that balance that
difference there don't have the money
saved up for that difference or I'm not
able to get a personal loan um to even
cover
that um I went to two credit unions my
personal Credit Union and then the
credit union that the cars financed
through that they said my debt to income
ratio was just too high in order to
approve the level the credit union that
your car is going through is
confused uh you and boyfriend need to go
sit down with that credit union and talk
to the manager and here's how it sounds
okay Mr
manager you have a
$199,000 car loan and a
$113,000 personal loan because you have
a
$32,000 car loan that only has $199,000
worth of collateral so you're unsecured
right now for 13,000 if you have to take
the car back and repo it you're going to
be unsecured for even more than
that this is you telling the manager
this you following
me yes and so I asking you to allow us
to sign a note for the
difference the amount that the car won't
bring gets the strain off of your bad
loan off of him my
boyfriend and all you're doing is
admitting that this loan is only
partially
collateralized he already doesn't have a
collateralized loan because the car is
upside down 13k you follow
me yes just explain that to him
sometimes you have to say that out loud
cuz sometimes a credit union manager
hasn't thought this
through and if they thought it through
then they would go oh I have a much
higher likelihood of getting my
$113,000 amount that were upside down if
I let this guy out of the
19 by selling the
car cuz the 13's not collateralized
anyway then you we've reduced your
problem to a $133,000 problem and then
you and said boyfriend take six jobs and
pay off the 13,000 before you pay off
anything
else and never sign a loan
again with someone you're not married
to see I didn't yell did I I did good
very kind calm Dave thank you thank you
it was almost story time was so
relaxing does that make sense to you
Lisa you I mean that's the only way I
know to get you out other than you guys
both go work 60 80 hours a week and come
up with
13k yeah okay I'll I'll try that yeah he
can't keep the car
and and you guys have not had this
discussion and he's being a little boy
and hasn't admitted it yet he's doing
harm to the person he claims to
love
you yeah because he can't pay the
bill we know that because he hasn't been
paying the bill and it's messed up your
credit am am I missing
something no no does he make a
year um he makes about 55 yeah, yeah so
the car was a bad purchase
anyway buying buying a $32,000 car when
you make 55 is not is out of line even
if you pay cash for it now was just did
you guys put anything down on this or
was this no no no nothing down with a
cosigner rolled negative equity from the
deal before into it didn't you yes
that's right yeah that's why you're in
13 upside down already yeah that
explains it there's no way you'd be that
far in the hole otherwise oh unless it
was the world's worst car but yeah um
what kind of car is
it it's a 2021 Honda Elantra okay nice
car yeah okay so where's his head on
this Lisa what's he gonna
say um so we've actually both been
trying to get rid of it he's on board
with getting rid of it but yeah he's not
able to do much um he's relying on me
because I have the the better credit to
yeah you used to before he came along
yeah
well it hasn't been reported yet um but
he's been behind and I'm just afraid
that it is going to start being reported
and then it's going to take both of our
credit scores yeah yeah well it's going
to for sure and
um in the meantime what you've got is a
high debt to income ratio which is
keeping you from getting the other loans
right yes that's not the damage it's not
damage credit that you got other debt so
what do you
make um 60 okay she got $5,000 income
between the two of
you I think we need to cut down to beans
and rice rice and beans and take two
more extra jobs and sell everything in
sight and get these messes cleaned up if
I were in you guys shoes that's what I
would do but this is just this horrible
experience for you and for him for that
matter has been y's wakeup call we just
made a mistake and uh Lisa if if if you
were the only person who ever made a
mistake about a car or co-signing for a
car in America we George and I wouldn't
have a job thank you for job security
it's like the largest mistake people
make George well I hope listeners are
going oh that's why I shouldn't cosign
because a lot of people think I'm doing
them a favor I love this person and then
they get themselves in a pickle and it
damages the relationship yeah and their
own Financial world you know the worst
one is something that's in this case
Lisa's boyfriend is being fairly mature
and is already saying hey yeah we got to
I'm going to help we got to get rid of
this car how do we do this he's
depending on her to get the money but um
but he was before but he's at least he's
not saying no I don't want to sell my
car thank God I was afraid he was gonna
be that guy whiny toddler but yeah but
the uh the worst one was like the
grandpa co-signs for the the 21-year-old
grandson's pickup truck oh gosh and now
they can't find junior he just took off
disappeared and doesn't pay the bill and
Grandpa's now on the hook for the whole
puppy CU they can't even find the truck
to repo it and Grandpa was probably
broke to begin with and broke unhe
hearted cuz it's his grandson you know
this is the stuff we deal with every day
around here and the holidays get real
awkward yeah well a awkward for them cuz
the kid's gone we can't find him but you
know gosh it's just uh that you know but
the problem is he'll never come back to
his grandpa because of Shame mhm even if
the grandpa forgives him it doesn't
matter at that point he it's a prodal
it's a you know he has to wake up in the
pig sty to come home now but the shame
to come back and so he's lost his
relationship with his grandfather that's
sad that's priceless that's what happens
a lot with these things and so Proverbs
17:18 says one lacking in sense signs a
loan for
another the new contemporary English
version says it is stupid to
cosign I like that version it's pretty
plain I've cosigned before by the way
Lisa has co-signed before I got to pay
it one guy co-signed for me when I went
into bankruptcy he got to pay it and I
had to go back and pay him back later
but his wife still pissed and the
assumption is that well I'll never pay
they'll be good they'll be able to make
the payments I just helped them get the
loan yeah but of course that's wrong or
they wouldn't have required a co-signer
you know they require a co-signer
because we couldn't pay and why the
lender says you're going to take the
risk not us exactly that's it I was not
credit worthy at the time the guy
co-signed for me and guess what we
proved it you know I mean oh it's just
awful it's a horrible thing but it's
it's one of those codependent things
where we feel like we're doing something
nice and you're doing a nice thing in a
wrong way that becomes hurtful rather
than a blessing